am 6 juni ist in sachsen anhalt
landtagswahl und wir haben auf youtube
die userinnen und user gefragt welche
themen ihnen besonders wichtig sind oft
genannt wurde die digitalisierung dazu
treffe ich jetzt martin mein name ist
martin mertens bin 36 jahre alt kommen
hier aus stendal familienvater von zwei
kindern und ich bin selbstständiger web
designer entwickler webseiten und web
anwendungen für unternehmen in dem fall
die ebenfalls wieder solche digitalen
prozesse vereinfachen ob mit terminen
planungstools oder buchungstools oder
einfache webseiten lösungen das ist mein
hauptjob
ich persönlich möchte nicht mehr ohne
digitalisierung seien weil es mir viele
vorteile verschafft alleine für meinen
arbeitsalltag ich kann von überall aus
arbeiten
ich habe nicht mehr feste arbeitszeiten
sondern ich kann so ein stück weit
selbst entscheiden wann ich meine arbeit
ausführen
man merkt jetzt immer noch selbst
innerhalb von ständern dass wir gebiete
haben die nicht erschlossen sind wo man
jetzt gerade noch dabei ist und wenn ich
aus ständer rauskomme wurde das
natürlich noch prekärer
das heißt da gibt's ortschaften die sind
teilweise noch gar nicht angebunden und
haben schlecht dass mobiles internet und
generell schlecht das internet
die meisten unternehmen die wir hier in
der region haben hinken der technologie
so ein bisschen hinterher und versuchen
halt jetzt innerhalb der letzten zwei
jahre das nachzuholen und ihnen fehlt es
dort an erfahrungen an möglichkeiten
halt auch sich beratung einzuholen
in den meisten schulen hat man jetzt
innerhalb der letzten anderthalb jahre
versucht digitalisierung zu
implementieren auf eine art dass man
sagt hier ist geld und hier sind geräte
ich habe bei meinen eigenen beiden
kindern die letzten anderthalb jahre
festgestellt dass es extrem schwierig
ist dass sie mit der digitalisierung
umgehen können weil man hat ihnen
einfach nur hardware gegeben man hat
gesagt okay hier ist digitalisierung es
für die nachbarn kompetenz an der
fähigkeit diese dinge einfach zu
verwenden wie benutze ich das wie bringe
ich das in meinen alltag und wie kann
ich das vielleicht auch für die zukunft
fortführen
ich denke jede generation muss etwas
dazulernen mittlerweile auch die
jüngeren auch weil sie das bedienen sie
können zwar hardware bedienen oder ein
telefon heißt aber nicht gleich dass sie
wissen was sie damit tun und umgekehrt
ist es bei den älteren manchmal so dass
sie den weitblick haben dinge zu
unterscheiden aber nicht wissen wie sie
bestimmte dinge anwenden sollen
ich würde mir wünschen dass man
digitalisierung nicht nur als modewort
betrachtet sondern dass auf jeden
lebensbereich überträgt und dadurch
versucht dinge einfach zu verbessern
egal ob im umweltschutz in einem
bürokratie oder in generellen prozesse
meine frage an die parteien ist wie man
bürokratische hürden reduzieren kann und
dadurch digitalisierung vorantreiben
kann
und diese frage gebe ich weiter an den
politikwissenschaftler benjamin höhne
er hat die wahlprogramme der parteien
durchgearbeitet eine bürokratisierung
ist der politik ein wichtiges thema
wasser im beiprogramm wahlkampfaussagen
oft gebraucht wird sicherlich kann
digitalisierung der bürokratie helfen an
der ein oder anderen stelle schneller zu
schnelleren verfahren zu kommen aber ich
würde schon separat betrachten die
beiden bereiche dann etwas allgemeiner
gefragt was planen die parteien zum
ausbau der digitalisierung alle parteien
sich die digitalisierung auf die fahnen
geschrieben wir finden sogar separate
kapitel zur digitalisierung vor
bei der cdu bei den bündnisgrünen und
auch bei der fdp oder geht es dann an
einem flächenland wie sachsen anhalt vor
allem darum dass die ländlichen räume
von der digitalen welt nicht abgekoppelt
werden stichwort 5g und darüber hinaus
viele weitere interessante forderungen
neben der digitalisierung von verwaltung
auch die schaffung von digital medien zb
fazit ist fast alle parteien haben die
digitalisierung als ein sehr wichtiges
zukunftsthema erkannt die frage ist nur
wie schnell sie ihre ziele umsetzen
können ein thema das sehr viele hier in
sachsen anhalt umtreibt ist das thema
niedriglohn denn circa ein drittel der
sachsen-anhalter arbeiten für weniger
als elf euro 5 brutto in der stunde
das ist der so genannte
niedriglohnsektor was das für das image
des landes bedeutet und vereinigen für
die zukunft der jungen sachsen anhalter
das besprechen wir jetzt mit einem
studenten der hier aus magdeburg statt
richard huhn sänger 21 jahre alt student
der wirtschaftswissenschaften
aufgewachsen in der landeshauptstadt
aber nach seinem studium in hannover
zurück nach sachsen anhalt kommt die
aussichten dafür stehen nicht besonders
gut
ja als studierender erstmal natürlich
auch darauf angewiesen dass man nach
abschluss seines studiums auch chancen
auf dem arbeitsmarkt hat ja und mit so
einem hochschulabschluss treibt man
natürlich nicht unbedingt einen job im
niedriglohnsektor an
die arbeitgeber dies in der region gibt
sind sind oft von außerhalb gekommen
haben ihren sitz in anderen
bundesländern
und das ist eben so das was fehlt
unternehmen am besten natürlich
großunternehmen die auch regional
verwurzelt sind ja eher die ihren
hauptsitz auch ja was es braucht ist zum
einen auch im unternehmen die von hier
kommen also vielleicht eine eine
gründerkultur um leute auch wieder ins
land zu locken die die selbstständig
hier etwas aufbauen wollen
und wenn man ein bisschen weiter denkt
vielleicht auch so was wie eine vision
ja so ein größeres ziel was diese sache
neben unterordnet
die politik kann natürlich im endeffekt
nur anreize setzen um diese prozesse
eben in gang zu setzen
aber was ich auch als großes problem
ansehe ist einfach das image von sachsen
anhalt diese diese zahlen dass eben die
meisten leute im niedriglohnsektor
beschäftigt sind dass das wissen
natürlich auch viele und daran etwas zu
ändern dass es auch aufgabe der politik
weil sachsen anhalt sich jetzt nicht
darauf verlassen kann mit technologien
zu punkten die schon 30 40 jahre alt
sind sondern das muss jetzt versuchen
direkte führungsrolle einzunehmen bei
neuen technologien bei nachhaltigen
technologien weil das im zweifel auch
die sachen sind die sachsen anhalt nach
vorne bringen können mich hat's frage an
die politik in wahlkampfzeiten ja was
kann man tun damit es in sachsen hat
eben auch besser bezahlte jobs zu finden
gibt
unser politik experte benjamin höhne
weiß welche parteien sich wie darum
kümmern
die niedriglohn thematik ist ein
klassisches soziales thema das es im
osten von besonderer bedeutung das hängt
zum einen damit zusammen dass nach wie
vor die löhne gehälter im osten
niedriger sind als im westen und zum
zweiten dass viele jobs tariflich nicht
gebunden sind probleme was die parteien
haben wenn sie dagegen vorgehen wollen
ist das dass die mindestlohn
gesetzgebung eine bundesangelegenheit
ist keine landes angelegenheit zum einen
und zum anderen ist die tarifautonomie
gibt also das zusammenspiel zwischen
gewerkschaften und arbeitgebern um die
löhne gemeinsam in einer runde zu finden
wir sehen dennoch dass die parteien spd
und linkspartei sich gedanken machen und
zum beispiel das tariftreuegesetz
fordern
dann können wir auch den blick auf die
afg werfen und sehen dass die iaaf dass
dieses thema niedriglohn für die afg
offenbar kein thema ist sie erörtert es
nicht was in gewisser weise auch
sozusagen insofern aufschlussreich ist
da immer wieder angenommen wird dass die
afg auch die soziale karte im wahlkampf
spielt wer und in welcher konstellation
auch immer dieses bundesland nach der
landtagswahl regiert eins ist klar der
niedriglohnsektor muss kleiner werden
es müssen mehr zukunftssichere und gut
bezahlten jobs her vor allem um die
jugend im land zu halten und natürlich
auch um das image von sachsen anhalt
etwa
aufzupolieren am 6 juni ist landtagswahl
in sachsen anhalt und wir haben sie und
euch bei youtube gefragt welche themen
vor ort gerade besonders wichtig sind
ein thema das sehr häufig genannt wurde
ist der lehrermangel und was die politik
denn dagegen tun will deswegen treffe
ich jetzt medina sie hat nämlich
beschlossen hier in gardelegen lehrerin
zu werden
ich bin mir der schulze ich komme aus
gardelegen und bin 22 jahre alt ich
studiere förderschullehrer abend an der
martin luther universität in halle und
ich habe die beiden grundschulzeit
deutsch und sport ist halt schon früh
dass ich etwas mit kindern machen möchte
und durch meine aktivitäten im verein
auch als trainerin hat sich das
irgendwie immer mehr bestätigt und ich
denke ich bin bis jetzt ganz zufrieden
mit der wahl meines studiums als ich in
der schule war vor vier jahren abitur
gemacht da war es schon zu merken in der
oberstufe auf jeden fall weil oft
unterricht ausgefallen ist wenn zum
beispiel eine lehrperson krank war oder
so dann wurde das halt nicht irgendwie
ersetzt oder vertreten sondern es halt
leider ausgefallen im prinzip möglich
sei doch oft über kommilitonen oder auch
über freundinnen die jetzt schon an der
schule zum beispiel als aushilfskraft
arbeiten und da merkt man den mangel
dann schon deutlich dass sie zum
beispiel erzählen dass in unteren
klassen der musikunterricht zum beispiel
für ein halbes jahr komplett ausfällt
weil es da keine lehrperson gibt oder
der physikunterricht und dass sie glaube
ich auch oft ein fachlehrer in wechsel
haben dass sie dann mal ein halbes jahr
haben sie mit dem lehrer unterricht und
das zweite halbjahr zum beispiel haben
wir eine andere lehrerin unterricht die
sie vielleicht gar nicht so kennen würde
ich mich so an unsere schulzeit zurück
erinnern sagen wie immer cool wenn der
unterricht ausgefallen ist dass am ende
keiner mit ihr nachholt und jetzt im
studium vielleicht da stehst und sache
machen muss die looney gemacht hast
vorher da da denkst du ja in diesem
moment nicht dran also jetzt von meinen
kommilitonen in da kriege ich oft mit
dass viele sagen sie wollen auch in die
heimat zurück aber viele kommen halt
auch aus anderen bundesländern
brandenburg
sachsen die stadt gardelegen hat halt
das galileo projekt ins leben gerufen
dort werden halt stipendiaten besucht
die sich bereiterklären nach dem studium
wieder in die stadt gar link
zurückzukommen ich ja möchte halt auch
später er in unserem ländlichen raum
unterrichten vielleicht nämlich in
kleinere schule haben mit einer
geringeren schülerzahlen wo ich auch
viele schüler kennen und ich finde es
hier einfach ich finde ich einfach schön
ich würde dir einfach gerne bleiben
was hat denn die politik im prinzip vor
um den lehrermangel zu bekämpfen bzw
einfach zu mindern
ich gebe mir linas frage weiter an
politikwissenschaftler benjamin höhne
er hat sich die wahlprogramme der
parteien genau angeschaut
zuerst sollen dass die schulpolitik in
allen parteien in ein beiprogramm einen
hohen stellenwert einem das ist richtig
so weil die kulturpolitik mailänder
angelegenheit ist und sie als mutter
strauß an ideen die die parteien da
vorzuweisen haben
und das beginnt der klassischerweise bei
der lehramtsausbildung über das wichtige
thema der finanzen beim thema finanzen
vielleicht zwei punkte die man
hervorheben kann einmal sozusagen
finanzielle anreize für lehrerinnen
setzen in ländlichen räumen wo der
lehrermangel besonders eklatantes zum 1
und zum anderen das ist eine forderung
die von den linken parteien kommt dass
die entlohnung für lehrerinnen und
lehrer gleichgestellt wird dh damit
würde das grundschullehramt quasi
aufgewertet werden die parteien haben
den lehrermangel also alle auf dem
schirm
es ist aber wohl kein problem das sich
kurzfristig lösen
bis spätestens 2008 und 30 sollen die
braunkohlebagger im mitteldeutschen
revier still stehen auch hier im tagebau
profen im süden sachsen anhalts der
damit verbundene strukturwandel
beschäftigt nicht nur euch in unserer
community sondern vor allem die menschen
hier vor ort dennoch immerhin 5000 jobs
an der braunkohleindustrie fast fünf
milliarden euro sollen deshalb bis 2038
in den süden sachsen anhalts fließen für
einen erfolgreichen strukturwandel
diesen wandel wird man vor allem im
nahegelegenen zeit spüren ich treffe
einen mann der diesen prozess aktiv
mitgestaltet reinecke 67 jahre viel
beschäftigte rentner wurde die zeit kam
1974 wegen arbeit von köthen hierher bin
inzwischen darf ich sagen
leidenschaftlicher zeit sei ja ich
promotet verschiedene vereine und
initiativen so in der pressearbeit und
nach totti webseiten und bedient die
social media kanäle das jüngste
wichtigste aus meiner sicht ist die
webseite zeit im wandel de bus wo ich
dann rund um den strukturwandel im
beiträge schreiben und porträtiert wird
menschen die aus eigeninitiative hier in
der stadt für die stadt was tun
da bauen google ausstieg bedeutet
zunächst mal dass eine höhere anzahl
arbeitsplätze wegfallen
und auch damit verbunden natürlich
wertschöpfung für die region verloren
geht man das triftige region wenn es uns
nicht gelingt das aufzufangen doch
relativ hat es gibt einen hohen bedarf
an information zu dem strukturwandel und
es ist auch eine möglichkeit bürgerinnen
und bürger zwar nicht direkt aktiv aber
eben zumindest informell an den ganzen
prozessen zu beteiligen und sie wissen
zu lassen was in ihrer stadt zu welcher
zeit in sachen strukturwandel passiert
also meine arbeit betrifft ist
zielgruppen arbeit geht dahin den
frustrierten zu sagen guck mal es gibt
menschen die sich damit
auseinandersetzen
die da etwas tun und die optimisten
einzufangen und zu sagen kommt leute
lasst uns anpacken
[Musik]
also meine vision wäre dass es eine
wirtschaftsstarke region wieder wird mit
einem lebenswerten umfeld in der stadt
der ecke wie es ihre frage an die
politik wie konkret unterstützt uns das
land bei dem ziel zeit zu entweder
wirtschaftsstarken stadt zu entwickeln
diese frage gebe ich an den
politikwissenschaftler benjamin höhne
weiter haben sich alle parteien gedanken
drüber gemacht in einem parteien können
wir aussagen in den wahlprogrammen zum
beispiel die cdu möchte sachsen anhalt
von einem einer kohleregion in eine
zukunftsregion umwandeln so heißt es da
durch die stärkung erneuerbarer energien
auch die stärkung des
wissenschaftsstandorts taucht da oft da
sind sich die parteien im prinzip gar
nicht so uneins dass da was passieren
muss differenzen sind aber insofern
liegen der verletzten vor dass die
grünen den kohle ausstieg schneller
wollen und die afg die uhren ein stück
wieder zurückdrehen möchte das heißt zum
braunkohle-abbau wieder zurückkehren
möchte
die mehrheit der parteien möchte am
ausstieg aus der kohle festhalten es
braucht aber viele gute ideen und
initiativen damit die menschen hier vor
ort an den erfolg des strukturwandels
glauben
ein häufig genanntes thema
rechtsextremismus mehr als zwei drittel
aller politisch motivierten straftaten
in sachsen anhalt hatten 2020
rechtsextremen hintergrund betroffenen
amts und mandatsträger ehrenamtliche
hier in querfurt treffe ich hitze waren
abend und spreche mit ihm über
rechtsextremismus
ich bin da silva ein amt ich komme aus
querfurt ich wohne hier mit meiner
nadine und zusammen haben wir sechs
kinder bis corona kam war ich das okay
veranstaltungsservice es lief auch
relativ gut gleichzeitig bin ich hier im
stadtrat tätig in querfurt bin
ortsverbandsvorsitzender europa fraktion
die linke und ich bin ja auch noch
ehrenamtlich im bündnis quer wort für
weltoffenheit 2015 ging dann die
sogenannte flüchtlingswelle los ich habe
mich schützend vor diese flüchtlinge
gestellt
gegen fremden heißt gegen
menschenfeindlichkeit und dann gingen
auch die anfeindungen los man hat einen
dummen sprüche zugeworfen zecken back
oder ode an die fuzzy das konnte ich
immer noch ab ich habe versucht immer
auf die leute zuzugehen und diskurs zu
suchen
bis dann die ersten übergriffe
stattfanden zerstochene autoreifen auf
unser grundstück wurden geworfen oder
feuerwerkskörper abgeschossen oder bei
karnevalsveranstaltungen wurde meine
große tochter schon die treppe
angestoßen von bekannten neonazis aus
dem ort und ganz schlimm war dann auch
in der goethestadt bad lauchstädt dort
wurde ich dann zum beispiel während
einer veranstaltung späteren abend sind
am dj pult von zwei neonazis attackiert
zusammengeschlagen
die verrohung in der gesellschaft hat
dermaßen zugenommen und das hat alles
was damit zu tun mit dieser ganzen
geistigen brandstiftung von den rechten
netzwerken die wir hier in der region
richtig stark hatten
ich kämpfe ja eigentlich für
menschlichkeit für toleranz für
solidarität für humanität seitdem ich
intensiv in der öffentlichkeit dafür
kämpfe auch anträge im stadtrat oder im
kreistag dafür mit unserer fraktion
einbringen
seitdem an werde ich von seiten bekämpft
von leuten von denen ich früher nie
erwartet hätte also als erstes wünsche
ich mir von der landespolitik dass man
geschädigten opfern von rechter gewalt
dass man diese ernst nimmt dass man
diese nicht alleine lässt dass man
irgendwo eine ansprechstelle schafft
aufklärung schon in der schule schon im
schulbereich ich wünsche mir mehr
polizeipräsenz bereichs beamter die sich
auch diesen fällen widmen können liebe
landespolitik was werden sie in zukunft
gegen rechts gegen rechtsextremismus in
diesem land unternehmen silbernes frage
geben wir weiter an benjamin höhne
der politikwissenschaftler hat die
wahlprogramme mit blick auf das thema
rechtsextremismus untersucht seitdem
rechts terroristischen anschlag von
halle im jahr 2019 muss dieses thema
alle demokratischen parteien etwas
angehen wir sehen aber dass besonders
die linken parteien da sehr viel
aufmerksamkeit diesem thema widmen die
zivilgesellschaft zivilgesellschaftliche
organisationen initiativen eine viel
größere rolle bei der bekämpfung von
rechts spielen und gegen die cdu jedoch
sich eher bedeckt hält eher zurückhält
sehr stark auf den verfassungsschutz
also eine institutionelle bekämpfung von
rechts setzt und die afg dieses thema
gar nicht meiner kenntnis nach gar nicht
erörtert auch vermutlich weil sie das
rechtsextremistische spektrum bei der
nächsten landtagswahl ebenfalls im blick
hat sicher ist wie dem problem
rechtsextremismus begegnet wird darüber
entscheidet wer und in welcher
konstellation künftig in sachsen-anhalt
regiert